coronavirus is dealing the Chinese
economy a very serious blow the scope
that the viruses impact has already far
exceeded the 2003 SARS epidemic this has
led to the virtual shutdown of China the
world's second largest economy that in
turn has disrupted global supply chains
led to the collapse and international
commodity prices and cause major
disruptions to the world travel industry
marks slowing in the Chinese economy is
coming at a very bad time for the global
economy already before coronavirus the
Japanese and German economies were
heading for recessions Latin America was
being beset by widespread social unrest
and the Indian economy was grinding to a
halt unless the corona virus epidemic is
soon brought under control it is likely
that global economic conditions will
only worsen that's bound to reach your
shores and bound to make a difficult for
China to meet its commitments under the
us-china phase one trade deal
unfortunately it's far from clear that
the corona virus epidemic is anywhere
near to being under control how do you
think the corona virus will affect the
world economy let us know in our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI